[Music]
why illness we have protein chains in
our brains and bodies that almost
exclusively process THC the key element
in weed THC binds and activates these
cannabinoid receptors known as cb1 and
cb2 causing a decreased ability for
cells to communicate efficiently in the
brain this slowed and altered
communication results in various
psychoactive effects aka
the feeling of being on the part of your
brain that regulates hunger is the
hypothalamus and that just happens to be
where those cb1 receptors live even when
you're not stoned your cannabinoids are
in charge of sending your brandy I am
hungry alert when you ingest THC you are
artificially boosting the amount of
cannabinoids sending that message which
explains why you get the munchies when
you smoke you are creating the effect of
a temporary hippocampal lesion which
basically means temporary brain damage
so it's not that you're forgetting
what's happening you just aren't saving
it at all
[Music]
no nobody has ever died from smoking
marijuana the worst outcome is lung
damage but that holds true for any type
of smoking if you want to avoid damage
from smoke Beno still get high you can
eat drink inhale vapor or purchase
cannabis skin creams skin creams really
[Music]